[Music]
okay so it's been an amazing week and
hopefully you still have energy for some
more cool stuff because we have one more
cool announcement for you and we have
some Google magic in the demos in Google
we put customers front and center we
care deeply for the experience we
provide and we've been in a journey for
the last 15 years building planet-scale
services by doing that we learned a few
things we learned that experience is
driven by providing performance
reliability availability and in order to
provide those things we developed a
culture which we call site reliability
engineering and site reliability
engineering is a combination of people
which is all of you and many of us
practices which we'll talk a little bit
about and products that we are making
available to you as part of Google cloud
so we have cool demos we even have very
interesting giveaways at the end so I
recommend stay and to move to the
exciting stuff there's nobody better to
tell you more about that than the person
that branded and created site
reliability engineering the person that
his LinkedIn profile simply says if
Google stops working it's probably my
fault ladies and gentlemen please join
me in welcoming the VP of Google 24 by 7
Ben trainer
[Music]
thank you Mark so thank you all for
joining today I want to talk a bit about
a new product announcement that we've
got which is the launch of the
transparent cloud API and to do that
announcement instead of talking at you
myself about how cool it is and all of
the things we expose I actually want to
introduce someone more qualified myself
to talk about how useful this is linguae
n-- from snapchat please join me so
Lincoln
we all know that snapchat was an
incredibly popular application during
the FIFA World Cup 2018 things were
happening fast people were sending snaps
using their cool snapchat excuse me
and we also know that the load was
incredibly high it was one of the most
popular events ever
how did snapchat keep everything so
snappy right during the event how did
you guys end up stealing the show like
that please speak into the spectacles
and tell me right thanks Ben hi everyone
I'm Elaine green and Snapple engineer so
snapchat is a best camera to show the
moment with friends during the World Cup
there were traffic spikes or backhand
after each important goal which means
users were sharing their excitement at
this exact moment by sending snaps or
posting stories with our top-class
lenses publishers also created a lot of
water cap related stories for user we
really want our users to have the best
product experience on snapchat thus we
need a strong serene infrastructure that
achieves high availability and low
latency so to optimize the serving for
different types of stories we have this
complicated back-end which consists of a
great number of components each
component can depend on multiple cloud
services to run a complicated system
like this well we need a good morning
train to understand its performance we
also want to discover and would cost
issues fast but this is especially
challenging if you run your service on
the cloud
because often you will die on this cloud
products which are usually black boxes
in monitoring world let's simplify the
problem so if we take away all the
implementation details we will see some
simple diagram like this there are three
parts in the system client our services
and the cloud products just like what
people usually do in the cloud world our
services rely on this cloud product to
serve request from client and we try to
make the best use of this cloud product
so we can focus on the implementation of
our own business logic we wouldn't spend
effort we when you really intend the
wheels as well as this cloud product are
okay a meter or so it's quality
requirement and are also cost efficient
to tell whether the whole season is
running well we would add more entry in
different places so first we need to
understand the or or health needs of
this system so we do journey ad-serving
metrics including traffic arrows and the
latency to our service this metrics a
direct service level indicators that
tell us how well the system is running
and we also set up alerts on this
metrics so we can get a notification
when the serving quality degrades during
an outage we want to know which part of
the system is broken and a service can
have multiple internal components it can
also depend on other services for this
internal component we can add custom
metrics to measure their performance
directly and tell which path goes wrong
what about these outgoing dependencies
so people usually add constant metrics
to measure the errors and the latency
for the requests that go to a dependent
service these clients and metrics are
helpful there are strong signals to
indicate whether we are having issue
calling a dependent service but the
problem is they don't tell us where the
issue lies the issue can locate either
under color sight or the dependent
service side or it can be network issue
in the middle
yes people usually wanted to check the
serving matrix of this dependent service
so they can compare them with the
current set ones and only through this
kind of comparison we can get a better
picture of what is going on if we own
the product if we were on a dependent
service we can get a decent matrix
easily by either adding instrumentation
or just motoring a monitor agent to
collect this matrix if they are already
available but what if the dependent
service is a cloud product in the
traditional cloud world we can't get a
serving matrix of this product but now
Google is offering this metric between
with ability to its customers under this
transparent SLI effort so let's walk
through a real use case to see this how
this transparent SL images are helping
us with production debugging so let me
use this simple service as an example so
this is one of the sub component of the
complicated story services backhand
which is shown in previous slide and
this service is one of our storage
services that serve stories may have
data in search result so we used to type
something in the search bar to reduce
the search response size we don't
include the formatted for metadata of
these stories immediately the client
will only send a request to fetch the
for metadata of the story only when user
clicks on a story and we store these
stories for metadata in cloud spanner
and we build this simple serving layer
and deployed on gke
so this service just translated request
from client side into spanner curries
and execute the queries on spanner and
then returns the result back to the
client very straightforward way then
let's discuss how we're going to build a
dashboard to monitor this simple serving
stack so the most important question we
want to answer in this case is is this
story service performing well last we
add editor serving metrics in our first
row from left to right this chart are
requesting errors error ratio average
latency and the 99th percentile latency
these are all well known as
the signals we can get a good sense of
the service level just with just a
simple single glance at his role at this
service just a sing rap er of spanner so
when there is a production issue the
first thing we want to check is whether
they suspend the request are doing okay
so here's 2p we added this Seban the
client side matrix at the second row in
the past if we deceased something from
these two rows we would start to guess
maybe spanner is having issue but we
could not be 100% sure about it because
these kinds of metrics
don't tell us the full picture and it's
in your outage our users are impacted
and we really want to make of mitigating
the problem as soon as possible and we
wish we can see directly behind the
curtain and the shorter in this
procedure of verifying different
hypothesis sorry I luckily Google we
don't want to hear that yeah I don't
wanna hear it right now I don't think we
have to hear that yet let's keep looking
at this issue on the dashboard that
you've got okay so luckily Google now is
offering a solution with ability so we
can put this transparent spending
transparent SLI metrics on the Sutro
these metrics director Google site
performance indicators of how well
spanner is handling requests from this
particular snap service we will see us
almost soon how this metrics can help us
locate issue fast the rest rows are
resource metrics we always want to make
sure resources are provisioned properly
in the first row we have the truss to
show spanner resource metrics and
including per table spanner instances
civilization and per table operation
rate and the arrows in the last row we
have the trust monitor our services
resource and from left to right is
trader per instance EP organization
memory utilization and network traffic
so in or having a dashboard with these
five rows we can answer the question is
it a snap issue
or a Google issue faster during an
incident just assignment here Google
expose the dashboard API so we can
configure a dash more like these using
code and keep track of all the changes
in our code base this feature is
currently under early access program and
we really enjoy it
all right lingua there's that sound
again I think something might actually
be wrong what are you gonna do about it
yeah let me check the page don't panic
let's let's check the page oh okay this
is our silver ratio has jumped
significantly for this story service
don't panic let's open the dashboard and
take a look so now we are looking at the
dashboard
we've just build together right so
remember in the old days we would just
start wrong it's the first set of rows
and let's see in the first row or
certain metrics we can see some we can
see the error ratio has jumped with
latency which is a common scenario in a
production outage and it's usually
indicate they're either processing on
the server side is slow or their zones
throwback hands and number of arrows
that is climb as a request such a time
out and then let's look at the second
row or Spanier client metrics and we can
see this charts allow very well with
this in the first first row then it
seems spanner requests are taking longer
to return it's in a Google issue usually
at this stage we will fire a support
ticket to check with the support
engineers but now we don't have to now
we can look directly at the third row
this Spaniard transparent SMI metrics
and let's see this has no errors and we
can also see some latency increase but
if we take a closer look and compare the
numbers with the numbers in the first
rows we can find something interesting
client latency increase the 10 times
more than what the server-side shows so
it implies
maybe it's not our issue on Spanish side
and the Savannah side latency increase
can
a result of surgeries so any stage let's
continue investigating on a snap site
instead of filing on ticket
so let's look further down in a
dashboard from this spanner resource
metrics we can see our spending instance
actually are running with reasonable
serialization which is a Nemecek you
know the detergent support is a semana
static issue and then we move on to this
resource metrics of our service here we
go
we found when the eastern took place the
CPU realization of one of the server
instance jump to something crazy like
one hundred percent utilized while the
CPU utilization for other instances
dropped it usually indicates the traffic
is not balanced and one single instance
is serving almost all the traffic which
is pretty bad and we check around and
follow somewhere in just made a bad roll
the balancer configuration change so
let's just a fix it with our revert so
we've just gone through an example of
how we're using different metrics to
root cause our production issue this can
be just one personal version of the
story in which is transparent SEO
metrics helped us conclude it's a
snapset issue and we stable a lot of
time by not creating our force along
ticket to Google as you may know
communicating orders support ticket it's
very time consuming even if the support
engineers hour is responsive this is
because the protein yours needed to
understand your service your environment
and they were issue before they can
start investigation on their site and it
takes a lot of back-and-forth
communication for this code start the
whole story can be a different one if
when we look at the spanner SEO metrics
and found it's a Google set issue in
that case we can just the Korea ticket
and appoint the support engineers to the
exact metrics metrics we looked at which
also makes the communication faster so
as a summary we really like this
transparent si metrics as they give us
additional useful with ability and also
helping us save time in production
debugging no matter it is a Google issue
or not
alright thanks for listening to our
story that's me honey hello we're back
to ban Thank You Lincoln so yes as
Linwood has just illustrated this sort
of scenario actually happens every day
in production right things work
differently you have variations and one
of your first jobs especially if you
have that klaxon going off in the
background is to figure out what has
occurred right something has changed but
was it a user behavior was that a push
that you made is something going on in
the platform historically the way that
this would get done is you would look at
your application and then file a ticket
and you know 20 minutes later somebody
from the support would get back to you
and you joint debug and all this time
time is passing in your users are being
damaged and if you can make those
intervals Shorter's you can make the the
period between when the klaxon goes off
and when your service is working normal
again much much shorter all of your
users are happier and your engineers are
more quickly able to solve the problems
that they are introducing either
intentionally or otherwise with the
changes that they're making and so this
introduction of the transparent SLI and
the transparent API for all of Google
services is a huge step in that
direction it lets engineers at companies
like snapchat spend more of their time
developing and rolling out cool apps and
less time debugging problems so I'm
happy to announce today that the
transparent its allies are available for
all Google services and they give you
the same key signals that we actually
have learned to use internally at Google
in the site reliability team to manage
all of Google's infrastructures thank
you thank you the the you know this both
from my perspective helps everyone
develop and and keep running their their
favorite services on Google and it helps
us apply a little bit of what we've
learned over the last 15 years of
running Google's internal cloud and make
it easy for all of you to develop your
applications and it helps you minimize
the time between when something
unexpected occurs and when you've
accurately done a differential diagnosis
and if either said this is something
that we can change on our own or we need
to contact Google and if you do contact
Google you can send the screenshot that
your application monitoring has sped up
and we won't spend any time trying to
figure out what's going on we can dive
right
the heart of the issue finally even in
developing applications when nothing is
going wrong it's very useful to be able
to see details of what the backend
services are doing not just the median
latency or the error rate but actually
the latency distribution and what
happens you know over the course of the
last week and this lets you build
applications that are better suited to
the performance characteristics of the
infrastructure that you're running on if
you would like to learn more about this
and other cool production development
practices we have access today in
stackdriver and we also have access
today through our partner data dog who
takes a lot of this to the next level
and gives you integrated dashboards and
value-added services and we have v 9
which is the site reliability and
customer reliability engineering lounge
is open today until mid afternoon and if
you come by and visit not only will you
be able to talk to s eries and series
but we have free copies of our launch
edition of the second volume with the sr
e book which I highly recommend with no
bias at all and you'll be able to talk
to people and maybe even get your book
signed
so linguae thank you for showing us how
you will use this service thank you all
for attending the launch of this and I
want to now introduce Morgan who has
another announcement for you
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everybody thank you for coming I'm
gonna do a demonstration today of our
stackdriver
APM tools so for those of you who happen
to watch the keynote this morning or a
part of the keynote on Tuesday we made
reference to these in effect this
morning we did a live demo and so our
APM suite is aimed at developers first
and foremost so this re-themed suite
includes stackdriver trace which allows
you to view have requests propagate
through your application stackdriver
debugger which allows you to do
breakpoint style production at safe
breakpoint style debugging safely in
production and stack driver profiler
which is our newest addition it's a
continuous production profiler that
allows you to see how your code actually
executes while it's running so rather
than do a presentation or a deck I'm
just gonna do a live demo part of this
was captured in this morning's keynote
but part of it also the debugger part is
new and so I'm really excited to show it
to you so if we could switch the screen
to my laptop perfect so this is hipster
shop if you've gone to any of the
keynotes you're probably already
familiar with it it's a demo application
that's composed of I think seven or
eight services some of which are written
go some of which are written in Python
nodejs and finally dotnet core we've
gone in instrumented it so that it works
with stack driver and it's running on
google kubernetes engine this version is
not using a scale like the version of
the Tuesday demo not that that really
makes a difference also unlike the
version on Tuesday this version is
incredibly slow we were very happy it
wasn't like this during this Tuesday
presentation but we've gone and slowed
it down so we can find out why and so
you know I clicked on vintage typewriter
it takes a while to come up I click on
Add to Cart a lot of these interactions
are very very have exhibit very very
poor performance and because it's it
appears to be just all these general
interactions are slow things like
application level metrics like latency
metrics for particular service aren't
going to be especially useful because
with our for strongly interconnected web
of services a slowdown and one is going
to cause slowdowns in all of them what
we can use though is distributed tracing
and distributed tracing allows you to
track how a request propagates between
different parts of your application as
they actual
happen so this scatterplot here on the
vertical axis shows the latency of
captured requests on the horizontal axis
we have a time at which they were
captured and you can click between them
to view the different traces and when
you click on one you see what we call
the waterfall graph this waterfall graph
shows the different components of a
request so in this case it's the
different services that are hot between
as the trace was captured and so from
here we can see that this was a call
made to the cart endpoint of the
front-end service and then it went to
the currency service and recommendations
and finally started going to product
catalog service now we see two things or
a problem here
and we went over this in this morning's
keynote the first is that we're making a
ton of separate requests to product
catalog service this just seems like bad
design right like if we're if we're
viewing a set of data for a particular
product or looking at some of the cart
we should be probably be calling the
catalog the single batch request if
there's multiple products and if there's
only one product we should really only
be calling it once that's gonna take a
while to fix like there's some real
re-engineering there and I'm not gonna
bore you to tears in the demo while I
rewrite the application but the other
thing that we can investigate is why
these individual requests are slow so
even if we batch these up this would
take still far too long our trace that
had what's that 10 seconds of latency
would still have you know well over one
second if we batch together these
product catalog requests you can see
this individual component is already one
and a half seconds long and so the trace
doesn't help us go any deeper than that
right you can add custom components to
the trace using our API is but still
generally you want to understand how the
code is actually running and so to do
that we can jump to stack driver
profiler stack driver profiler is a
continuous production profiler is the
newest component of our APM sleep and it
actually to you as a developer you
basically turn it on your application
and forget about it and it continually
captures information about how your code
actually executes sin production the
nice thing about stack driver profiler
is that compared to sort of similar
entries in the market it has effectively
no performance impact so you can just
leave it running it in the background
which will sample itself it'll turn on
and off on various services at different
times and to you as a developer there's
basically no performance cost which is
why it's really nice and you don't have
to worry about it you don't turn it on
you don't have to like start profiling
sessions around them
it supports Heep thread profiling and
CPU profiling depending on the language
that you're on it'll also do wall time
profiling we're gonna jump into CPU
profiling if we see something we can see
something right away
the get product endpoint of this service
the G RPC method for it is really really
slow it's consuming 92 percent of our
system CPU if we run the language that
allowed all time profiling we'd also see
that and we can see that's effectively
all the time for it is taken up by this
parse catalog method and so what we can
do now is dive into the code and see
what's actually happening there so this
is parse rather this is the parts
catalog code here this is inside our
product catalog service it's written in
go and we can see here when it's called
it basically just does some JSON D
serialization and so from going from
trace we understood which service was
calling a slowdown for our application
without distributed tracing that would
have been incredibly difficult and now
with profiler we found the actual
function in our code that's slowing
everything down so in just a few minutes
or a few seconds depending how quickly
you went through this we can find out
exactly where our slowdown is caused and
this might seem like a bit of a
contrived example like in fact if you
looked at the code you see that I made
this use JSON serialization to slow it
down for a demo but for when we talk to
our customers this isn't so outlandish
right we've talked to many customers
where their services are slow because
they are just burning CPU Tainan John
serialization deserialization
or where they have things like regular
expressions or just functions that you
know you wouldn't even expect to show up
as a blip on a CPU charter or or really
a list of things that are slowing things
down and it's consuming 10 20 30 % of
their system CPU and so this is actually
an example that's really really
appropriate for things that our
customers have run into and so in the
demo this morning that I did at the
keynote we didn't redeploy the service
and fix the issue so I'm not going to do
that here and repeat everything what I
will show you is that between the
different versions of this code we can
compare their performance with the new
stack driver profiler comparison feature
and stack driver profiler comparisons
allows you to compare profiles from your
services either across versions across
different time periods or across
different regions and from this we can
see that the slow code here particularly
parse catalog has gone to effectively
zero
at CPU and even the get product endpoint
which of course is still there in the
new version is now down to effectively
0% CPU and we can use this to verify
that our code changes had the impact
that we expected obviously if you were
doing this in real life you'd want to
start by doing the metrics comparison of
latency just to verify that your changes
have worked but of this we know that the
change is inside the code have actually
had the effect that we wanted for
stackdriver trace we also have a similar
feature we can compare late to see
across time or cross versions or across
different areas so I mentioned that
stackdriver APM is composed of three
products so I mentioned stackdriver
trace I walked you through stackdriver
profiler
finally stack grabber debugger
stackdriver debugger just like the other
tools you can run safely and
continuously in production it is very
sort of magical in a sense it lets you
set breakpoints in your production
environment safely we call these
snapshots and so the best way to show
this is just a given
demonstration so the code I'm looking at
here is for the currency conversion
service this is a service where you can
call in give it a value in u.s. dollars
and tell it I want to know what this is
worth in euros the hipster shop store
lets you change currencies the currency
services what performs this so one of
the challenges that you might have of
the currency conversion service is that
it might be converting currencies in a
different manner than you expect or it
might be converting them with the wrong
values so the way the service works is
every hour or so it goes to a web
service I think hosted by the European
Central Bank Ursa playing like that that
lists their up-to-date currency
conversion rates so let's imagine that
you know you looked at those rates and
looked at the values of the currency
conversions service was outputting and
they didn't match today to debug this
you'd probably add a bunch of log
statements to the service to print out
what it thought that the current
currency conversion values were you'd go
and redeploy the app and which might
take a while depending on your
environment I need to see the output of
those logs with stackdriver debugger we
can short-circuit that all I have to do
is click here on line 123 in the
interface we've already captured a
snapshot
there's a load test running against this
and from here we can look at the local
variables like this data object and see
the actual values at weeks that the
service thinks in memory that it should
be converting these currencies at so
right away you can debug it and verify
if your hypothesis that the currency
conversion
wrong you could verify if that was
correct we also just like a traditional
debugger support full conditions so you
can tell it to only set a snapshot if
certain variables are set to certain
values and you can use expressions to
inspect the output finally you can
navigate through the different frame to
the call stack I admit that this is
probably not the greatest example
because this node function calls itself
a lot but you can also view the
variables within those different frames
so it gives you the power that you
expect with regular debugger without
halting execution without interrupting
your customers workflow which is really
really really excellent we use
technologies like this profiler and
trace everyday at Google and we're
really excited to show these to our
customers so we should talk about two
things with these the first question
that always comes up is how easy is this
to set up I can tell you from experience
from working on this demo app as well as
just of course working these products a
lot it's very very straightforward so we
do in process instrumentation simply
libraries that you link to your
application and redeploy it all of our
instrumentation is open source and
Apache licensed on github across all
languages for a trace and for debugger
we support Java go no js' dotnet Ruby
Python PHP so we've set a seven
languages for trace we additionally
support C++ for profiler it's relatively
new so we're still building out the
language support so we support Java go
and node and we're developing support
for Python right now and we'll continue
looking at the others for stackdriver
trace our instrumentation is through a
project that we started at Google we
still run called open census open census
is a set of language specific libraries
that will automatically capture traces
and application level metrics from
applications so for example in this
application here by adding open census
to one of the go parts the application
of these lines of code here we
automatically captured traces propagate
the context embedded annotations and
attributes of those traces and we
automatically captured application level
metrics so it's really easy to get
started with we've integrations across
all these languages for things like GRP
see various HTTP clients sequel clients
other storage clients client libraries
for Google and so on and we try and make
it as automatic as possible
open census is also great because we've
this concept of exporters and this is
the reason the open sentence is a
community
rather than just a Google project so
when you set up open census we told it
to export stackdriver
but if you were using other other APM
solutions we mentioned data dog earlier
you can export to data dog bio consensus
or Prometheus or zip can or SolarWinds
or others you can export your data to
your back-end of choice and if open
census you can export your data even to
multiple backends at the same time which
is really powerful so we've made this
really easy to get started with you
simply link a few libraries including
open census to your application they'll
automatically capture the writes lemma
tree redeploy your app you can get
started of stackdriver 8:00 p.m. the
pricing on stackdriver APM is extremely
competitive debugger and profile are
currently free a trace has a pretty
generous free tier and then there's a
paid tier after that that goes into
effect in September compared to
competing solutions it's like a tiny
minuscule fraction of the cost so with
that I'm done the demo and we'll move on
to the next speaker thank you very much
[Music]
you
[Music]